[Music]
how special is this place very special
it's like like we never left Priscilla
Presley the request I want to be buried
next to Elvis at Graceland it's been as
you know uh my home for a long time the
response deny the ask according to TMZ
came during Priscilla and granddaughter
Riley keough's negotiations as they went
to court over Lisa Marie's estate I'm
pleased to inform everyone that the
parties have reached a settlement but
here's what's interesting if Priscilla
were to be buried next to Elvis it
wouldn't be easy and would require some
excavation Elvis's grave is between his
grandmother Minnie Mae Presley and his
father Vernon his mother Gladys is just
to the right the grave of Lisa Marie's
son Benjamin was actually slightly moved
to make room for his mom the two are
laid to rest just a few feet away from
Elvis on the other side of the backyard
fountain this was a sanctuary this was
his life you know Graceland PT's toured
Graceland many times and the estate was
beloved by Elvis and Priscilla during in
the six years they were married I was a
girl that basically was left to take
care of Graceland is the upkeep on
Graceland terribly draining on the
estate very much so absolutely this has
been a major point in 1982 Priscilla
opened Graceland to the public we have
memories that's home it really is and we
try to keep it and maintain it that way
it's a living breathing home new things
all the time the visitors come in and
despite Priscilla's devotion you have to
wonder what would Elvis think of her
supposed request they were divorced in
1973. we always had a continuing
relationship our relationship really
never ended you know we were had a very
loving relationship
still appeared to clarify her intentions
in a statement implying that she doesn't
necessarily need to be right next to
Elvis quote although I don't plan on
going anywhere anytime soon it is my
family's and my wish for me to be laid
to rest with my daughter and the love of
my life when that time comes the family
is happy and United and excited to be
looking forward and moving forward
together as a family